الدعم اوكرانيا بالدبابات الثقيله صاحبه
صدا كبير لكنك الساعيه لاختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه المحصنه تطالب باكثر من الدبابات
اوكرانيا تحتاج الى تلقي صواريخ بعيده
المدى و طائرات مقاتله طلب الاوكرانيون
اخر على طاوله الحلفاء الغربيين
ومفاوضات تجرى مع الغرب لتوليد تلك
المقاتلات والدبابات لوحدها لا تكفي ولم
تكون الرصاصه الفضيه التي تسمح لكييف
بالانتصار في الحرب ووفقا نيويورك تايمز
مع كل ذلك يجب ان يحدث تغيير جذري في
الجيش الاوكراني الولايات المتحده ودقيه
الحلفاء يتوجب عليهم تدريب الجيش
الاوكراني بحيث يتمكن من استخدام هذه
المعدات الحديثه
الدعم العسكري واحداث توازن على الارض هدف
تسعى له اوكرانيا برفقه دائميها على امل
احداث تغيير حقيقي هنا في ساحه المعركه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه